[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serien Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend und mit mir im Studio für
den Sport des christianotto sehr gern
guten Abend und hier sind unsere Themen
an diesem Donnerstag
erste Kampfflugzeuge für die Ukraine
polen will in den nächsten Tagen vier
mit 29 Jets liefern
macron unter großem Druck Frankreichs
Regierung drückt die umstrittene
Rentenreform durch ohne Abstimmung im
Parlament
und grünes Licht für Finanzierung der
Bundestag beschließt die Einführung des
49 Euro tickets
[Musik]
beim Thema Waffen für die Ukraine bahnt
sich ein neues möglicherweise
kriegsverändern des Kapitel an Polens
Präsident du da verkündete heute vier
Kampfjets vom Typ mit 29 an die Ukraine
zu übergeben und weitere sollen folgen
was Polens Ankündigung auch brisant
macht ist die Frage ob die Lieferung mit
deutscher Erlaubnis erfolgen müsste weil
es sich um Kampf jetzt handeln könnte
die von der DDR übernommen wurden
Florian neuhahn berichtet
schon seit Tagen hatten polnische
Regierungsvertreter diesen Schritt
angedeutet Kampfjets in die Ukraine zu
liefern heute ist es der polnische
Präsident du da die bei einem Treffen
mit seinem tschechischen Kollegen der
die Ankündigung macht
11 in den kommenden Tagen werden wir
soweit ich weiß vier voll einsatzbereite
Flugzeuge in die Ukraine überführen
weitere werden gewartet und vorbereitet
und nach und nachgeliefert werden
es geht um mit 29 alte Kampfflugzeuge
sowjetischer Bauart der Vorteil
ukrainische Piloten kennen sich mit dem
System aus könnten die Jets daher
schnell nutzen die meisten der
polnischen Kampf jetzt stammen aus alten
Beständen der Nationalen Volksarmee der
DDR wurden wie hier Anfang der 2000er
Jahre von Deutschland an Polen übergeben
genau solche Jets aus alten DDR
Beständen so berichtet der polnische
Präsident du da heute würden nun an die
Ukraine geliefert dafür aber müsste
Deutschland als Herkunftsland zustimmen
doch der deutsche Verteidigungsminister
weiß am Nachmittag von nichts ich war
bislang keine Bestätigung aus Polen dass
das passiert ist ich kenne die
medienmeldung aber keine Bestätigung
dass das tatsächlich die Absicht ist und
wann und ich habe auch insbesondere
keine Bestätigung darüber dass es Mix
sind aus alten DDR-Beständen Kampfjets
für die Ukraine es ist eine neue Stufe
der militärischen Unterstützung des
Westens doch die Ankündigung aus Polen
lässt heute noch einige Fragen offen
ja über diese kampfjetlieferung sprechen
wir jetzt mit sharkunta la benaji in
Berlin und Florian neuhahn in Brüssel
auch zuständig für die NATO aber
zunächst nach Berlin zu dir was sagt man
denn dort in Berlin zur Ankündigung aus
Warschau also hier in Berlin liegt
derzeit noch gar kein Antrag aus
Warschau vor und es ist auch noch unklar
ob es sich tatsächlich um alte DDR
Flugzeuge handelt und ob dann also die
Bundesregierung zustimmen müsste das
wird momentan noch vom
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium und vom
Bundesverteidigungsministerium geprüft
sollte der Antrag denn dann kommen dann
wäre das tatsächlich das erste Mal dass
sich die Bundesregierung direkt zur
Lieferung von Kampfflugzeugen in die
Ukraine Verhalten müsste damit hat sie
sich ja bisher schwer getan man müsste
dann abwarten ob es wirklich als
kriegsverändernder Eingriff oder als
Kriegs verändernde Lieferung gewertet
werden würde denn es haltet handelt sich
ja hier um alte Kampf Flugzeuge und man
muss auch dazu sagen die Bundesregierung
hat ja mittlerweile keinen roten Linien
mehr bei Waffenlieferungen die Sie
wirklich klar zieht das heißt ein Jahr
zu einer solchen Lieferung wäre nicht
gänzlich ausgeschlossen dann weiter nach
Brüssel Florian was würden Kampfjet
Lieferungen an die Ukraine für die NATO
bedeuten das ist natürlich eine ganz
neue Stufe in der militärischen
Unterstützung des Westens für die
Ukraine zumal es ja vor kurzem noch
gewichtige NATO-Staaten gab die das
Rundweg ablehnten etwa Deutschland aber
eben auch die USA die Sorge war ja dass
groß vor einer Eskalation durch Angriffe
mit diesen kampflugzeugen auf russisches
Gebiet
Befürworter sagen dass es dagegen zwei
Gegenargumente gibt erstens diese
kampflokzeuge sind wirklich sehr alt 45
Jahre in etwa und zweitens hat Russland
eine funktionierende Luftabwehr würde
also ukrainische Piloten sofort
abschießen das heißt die Ukraine wäre
der solche Angriffe auf keinen Fall
starten heißt es ja und dann gab es
heute so etwas wie ein Freibrief der
Amerikaner für diese Lieferung dort hieß
es jedes Land könnte selbst entscheiden
ob es eigene Kampfflugzeuge an die
Ukraine liefern Wolle und ja polen will
diesen Freibrief nun offenbar nutzen
dann vielen Dank nach Berlin und Brüssel
ja und Florian
zum ersten Mal seit Beginn des
ukrainekriegs sind ja die USA und
Russland direkt aneinander geraten wir
haben schon ausführlich darüber
berichtet es geht um den Absturz einer
US-Drohne über dem Schwarzen Meer für
den Washington Moskau verantwortlich
macht jetzt veröffentlichte das
US-Militär ein Video davon die Aufnahmen
stammen offensichtlich von einer
Bordkamera der Drohne zu sehen ein
russischer Kampfjet der Treibstoff auf
die Drohne ablässt bei einem weiteren
Anflug eines Jets bricht das Video dann
ab danach ist der beschädigte Propeller
der Drohne zu sehen Russland bestreitet
eine Schuld an dem Absturz
jetzt nach Frankreich wo die Menschen
seit Wochen gegen die heftig umstrittene
Rentenreform auf die Straße gehen es
geht als das zentrale Projekt in der
Amtszeit von Präsident macron heute
peitschte er die Reform quasi im
Alleingang durchs Parlament möglich
durch einen politischen Kniff und macron
geht mit diesem Manöver einen hohes
Risiko jetzt könnte ein
Misstrauensantrag gegen die Regierung
Folgen anderersberg berichtet
kurz nach 15 Uhr kurz bevor die
Nationalversammlung über die
Rentenreform abstimmen soll da greift
die französische Regierung zum
verfassungskniff mit Artikel 49.3 wird
die Rentenreform ohne Abstimmung im
Parlament durchgeboxt die einen grünen
die Nationalhymne die anderen Buhn
und die Premierministerin versucht sich
Gehör zu verschaffen
175 Stunden Debatten im Parlament dürfen
nicht umsonst gewesen sein wir können
das Risiko nicht eingehen den Kompromiss
den Senat und Parlament ausgehandelt
haben zerbrechen zu lassen wir können
keine Wette auf die Zukunft unserer
Rente eingehen diese Reform ist
notwendig die
Opposition will das der Regierung nicht
durchgehen lassen sie spricht der Reform
ihre Legitimität ab und droht mit
Misstrauensantrag und mehr
er spricht Bände das Artikel 49.3 schon
wieder gebraucht werden musste um den
Willen des Volkes zu übergehen jetzt
müssen wir mit den Gewerkschaften in
Aktion treten und alles tun damit das
Gesetz zurückgezogen wird
damit ein Misstrauensantrag angenommen
wird müssten mindestens die Hälfte der
Abgeordneten der Nationalversammlung
dafür stimmen die Stimmung kocht auf den
Straßen Frankreichs mit spontanen
Demonstrationen und viel Wut
so Einordnung gehen wir nach Paris zu
Thomas Walde Thomas was bedeutet das
denn jetzt für das Land und macrons
Regierung
also formal ist es durchaus möglich dass
die Regierung am Ende ihre formprojekt
auf diese Art und Weise durch das
Parlament bekommt das hat sie mit
anderen Gesetzen auch schon getan aber
dieser Fall ist dann doch politisch
besonders wegen der besonderen Bedeutung
die die Rentenreform für die politische
Agenda von Emanuel macron hat seine
Regierung zeigte sich in den vergangenen
Tagen und Wochen doch sehr
zuversichtlich dass sie eine ordentliche
Mehrheit im Parlament dafür zustande
bringen würde sie hat dazu Kompromisse
eingegangen mit den konservativen
republiker am Ende muss man sagen hat es
nichts genutzt und die Regierung steht
nun doch ein bisschen belämmer da sie
ist politisch geschwächt
opposition und Gewerkschaften hatten
zuvor schon gesagt dass hier ein Gesetz
gegen den wie sie sagen Willen des
Volkes durchgedrückt werden soll die
fühlen sich heute Abend bestätigt sie
wird ein gewisser meisten Blut im Wasser
kündigen bereits neue Demonstrationen
gegen die Regierung und ihr Vorhaben an
danke schön nach Paris Thomas Walde
ja es sind unruhige Zeiten aktuell auch
in der Finanzwelt erst die Pleite der
amerikanischen Silicon Valley Bank dann
die Vertrauenskrise bei der Schweizer
Großbank Kredit Suisse und trotz dieser
Turbulenzen will die EZB weiter gegen
die Inflation kämpfen und die ist nach
wie vor hoch in Deutschland lag sie
zuletzt bei 8,7 %. darum hat die EZB
jetzt zum sechsten Mal in Folge den
Leitzins angehoben um 0,5 Punkte auf
3,5% Stefan Schlösser
die Pleite der Silicon Valley Bank löste
Schockwellen aus der amerikanische
Präsident musste Kunden und merkte
beruhigen versprach dass alle Einlagen
sicher sein jetzt die Schieflage bei der
Schweizer Kredit suis hier springt die
Nationalbank ein und wird umgerechnet
bis zu 50 Milliarden Euro bereitstellen
entscheidend ist ja dass sie Ruhe
reinkommt das also die Kunden die
Einleger die Geld ja der Chris gegeben
haben das Gefühl haben da brennt nichts
an wenn ich mein Geld haben will bekomme
ich das eben auch das ganz entscheidend
trotzdem Turbulenzen im Bankensystem
bleibt die EZB auf Kurs und erhöht
weiter die Zinsen die
Inflationsbekämpfung hat Vorrang dennoch
sei die EZB vorbereitet
in jedem Fall ist unser geldpolitisches
Instrumentarium voll ausgestattet um das
Finanzsystem des Euro-Währungsgebiets
bei Bedarf mit Liquidität zu
unterstützen
die Credit Suisse wird als
systemrelevant eingestuft eine Pleite
könnte verheerende Auswirkungen auf die
Weltwirtschaft haben der Aktienkurs war
zeitweilig um 30% eingebrochen die Sorge
der Bank könnte die Liquidität ausgehen
auch wegen der schnellen Zinsschritte
der Notenbanken viele Geldhäuser haben
Kapital in langfristigen anleiden
gebunden wird jetzt Geld abgezogen
müssen die Banken die Anleihen mit
Verlusten verkaufen das europäische
Finanzsystem ist sicherlich besser
aufgestellt als vor der letzten
Finanzkrise die Banken haben größere
Kapitalpuffer aber auch die europäischen
Banken haben damit zu tun dass die
Zinsen steigen die Werte von Anleihen
fallen und auch die europäischen Banken
haben damit zu tun dass das Vertrauen
jetzt erschüttert ist der Fall der
kritis hieß zeigt dass Risiken im
Finanzsystem nicht ganz auszuschließen
sind die Gefahr eines Übergreifens auf
andere Geldhäuser gilt zurzeit aber als
er gering
ja um Finanzen ging es auch sehr lange
beim Streit zwischen Bund und Ländern um
das sogenannte deutschland-ticket 49
Euro soll es ab dem 1 Mai pro Monat
kosten und anknüpfen am riesigen Erfolg
des 9€-tickets heute beschloss der
Bundestag mit der Ampel Mehrheit die
Finanzierung bis 2025 normalerweise
Ländersache beteiligt sich der Bund pro
Jahr mit 1,5 Milliarden Euro Volker Duce
wer vom neuen deutschlandticket redet
kommt nicht am 9 euro-ticket vorbei eine
Fahrkarte die im nah und Regionalverkehr
zum Sommerhit wurde 52 Millionen
Fahrgäste in nur drei Monaten das 49 €
Ticket klingt wieder teurere Bruder es
geht bundesweite nah und Regionalverkehr
ist monatlich kündbar ist aber nur
digital buchbar hier melden sich schon
die ersten Kritiker das alleinige buchen
am Computer oder Handy Grenze älterer
und ärmere Bevölkerung Schichten aus
sagen Sozialverbände die Länder greifen
tief in die Tasche um den öffentlichen
Nahverkehr zu stärken 1,5 Milliarden
jedes Jahr drei Jahre lang bis 2025 der
Bund gibt noch einmal die gleiche Summe
dazu
Deutschland bleibt ein Flickenteppich
auch trotz des deutschland-tickets
einige Länder halten nämlich an
zusätzlichen Ermäßigungen für bestimmte
Gruppen fest Tickets für Auszubildende
und junge Leute bezuschusten viele
Länder wie Niedersachsen Thüringen
Sachsen das Saarland und Bayern
ermäßigte Fahrkarten und Abos für
Einkommen schwächere Schichten bieten
zum Beispiel Berlin Hessen
Baden-Württemberg noch sind beim 49 Euro
Ticket nicht alle Fragen geklärt etwa
darf man Fahrräder mitnehmen oder Tiere
und kostet das dann mehr darf man sich
in die erste Klasse setzen Fragen über
die die Verkehrsministerkonferenz in der
nächsten Woche beraten will
Anfang der Woche wurde der große
Kahlschlag bei Galeria Karstadt Kaufhof
öffentlich jetzt gibt es eine Rettung
für weitere fünf Filialen nachdem die
Vermieter Zugeständnisse gemacht haben
erhalten bleiben jetzt auch die Galeria
Karstadt Filialen in Oldenburg Rostock
Leipzig erlangen und in Bayreuth 82
Warenhäuser bundesweit werden
fortgeführt 87 pardon werden geschlossen
tausende Mitarbeiter verlieren wegen der
Insolvenz ihren Job
wie und wo geflüchtete unterbringen wie
die Kosten verteilen darüber wird schon
länger gestritten Länder und Kommunen
sehen sich längst an der
Belastungsgrenze und fordern deutlich
mehr Geld vom Bund auch heute beim
Treffen der Ministerpräsidenten in
Berlin
2022 gab es in Deutschland rund
218.000 Erstanträge auf Asyl deutlich
mehr als in den Jahren zuvor ein Trend
der sich offenbar auch 2023 fortsetzt
bislang stellten mehr als 54.000
Asylsuchende einen Erstantrag im Mai
wollen Bund und Länder zu einem
flüchtlingsgipfel zusammenkommen
Israels Premierminister netanjau ist
momentan zu Besuch in Berlin daheim
kämpft seine rechtsreligiöse Regierung
derzeit mit den größten Protesten seit
Jahrzehnten seit Wochen demonstrieren
10.000 im gesamten Land sie blockieren
Straßen und ziehen eine rote Linie gegen
die geplante Justizreform
die Demonstranten sehen die Demokratie
in Gefahr und in Berlin ist die
spannende Frage wie Bundeskanzler Scholz
mit diesem Thema umgeht Daniel dazu
es war ein Tag sehr starker sehr
unterschiedlicher Emotionen zunächst
Besuch eines Bahnhofs in Berlin
Grunewald von dem aus viele tausend
Menschen in den tote portiert wurden
exakt von hier man kann ja nicht stehen
ohne dass ein die ganzen Erinnerungen
hochkommen an die Geschichte an die
furchtbare Zerstörung jüdischen
lebenslang Europa
durchgeführt von Deutschen und deshalb
werden wir die Verantwortung die wir aus
dieser Geschichte haben
nicht vergessen eine zweite
Verantwortung mahnten unterdessen heute
auch viel in Deutschland lebende
Israelis an bei parallel stattfinden
Protesten gegen Justizreform die Sorge
echte sind arabische Leute und das
können wir nicht erlauben die
strengesicherten Gespräche im Kanzleramt
zogen sich Themen der Iran gemeinsame
Rüstungsprojekte die Ukraine und die
Justizreform als demokratische
wertepartner und enge Freunde Israels
verfolgen wir diese Debatte sehr
aufmerksam und das will ich nicht
verhehlen mit großer Sorge
die Unabhängigkeit der Justiz ist ein
hohes demokratisches gut darin sind wir
uns einig niemand müsste sich Sorgen so
seine Entgegnungen die geplante Reform
verschlechtere die Gewaltenteilung nicht
sondern verbessere sie die Vorwürfe aus
Israel Design Bruch mit der Demokratie
sind nicht wahr Israel war Israel bleibt
eine liberale Demokratie nicht anders
sondern so stark und lebendig wie zuvor
und so wie Europa heute ist
danach Besuch beim Bundespräsidenten der
sich jüngst ebenfalls besorgt zur Lage
in Israel geäußert hatte eine
Freundschaft in nicht eben einfachen
Zeiten
manche Vollmer war die erste grüne
Vizepräsidentin des Bundestags jetzt ist
sie im Alter von 79 Jahren nach langer
Krankheit gestorben die promovierte
evangelische Theologen zog 1983 erstmals
in den Bundestag ein und wurde kurz
darauf Teil einer rein weiblichen
dreierspitze der grüne von 1994 an war
sie 11 Jahre Vizepräsidentin im
Bundestag und der erinnerte an sie am
Mittag mit einer Gedenkminute
so jetzt zum höchsten Amt im Fußball
Christin Gianni Infantino darf sich
weiter als FIFA Präsident sorgen ja sein
macht Mensch durch und durch passt genau
zu ihm ohne Gegenkandidat wurde der
Schweizer Gianni Infantino in Kigali
Ruanda auf dem wichtigsten Posten des
internationalen Fußballs bestätigen der
52-Jährige bleibt also für weitere vier
Jahre FIFA Präsident da strahlte über
das ganze Gesicht der alte und neue
FIFA-Präsident Janine von Tino die
aklamation zur Wiederwahl allerdings
nicht so euphorisch wie er sich das
gewünscht hätte die deutschen Norweger
Schweden denen und auch andere
europäische Verbände verzichten auf den
Applaus für ihn das ist ein Zeichen
denke ich dafür dass wir sehr
unzufrieden waren zuletzt mit der FIFA
nicht nur das hat nicht nur mit Katar zu
tun sondern auch mit vielen anderen
Themen Transparenz ist eine Frage die
Sitzung der Menschenrechte eine andere
Frage die für uns sehr bedeutungsvoll
ist Johnny und fantino aber kann sich
auf die Unterstützung von fast 200
Verbänden weltweit verlassen und
Rekordeinnahmen von 7,5 Milliarden
US-Dollar für die FIFA das sich jetzt
seine Macht
die schweren Krawalle in Neapel rund um
das Achtelfinale Rückspiel in der
Champions League mit acht Festnahmen und
sechs verletzten Polizisten drängen das
sportlicher aus von Eintracht Frankfurt
in den Hintergrund so respektvoll die
beiden Teams miteinander umging so
abstoßend vorher die Gewaltakte zwischen
den niedersten Gruppierungen bei der
Fanlager italienische Medienberichten
heute dass der erste Angriff von
Hooligans Neapels verübt wurde danach
aber wüteten auch die Frankfurter dann
will ich das nicht dass Frankfurt Fans
bezeichnen sondern als als gewalttätige
Gruppe ähm von der wir uns auch denke
ich schleunigster distanzieren sollen in
der Nachspielzeit der ersten Hälfte der
Führungstreffer Neapels durch osimehn
der Nigerianer hatte bereits beim 2:0 in
Frankfurt getroffen und markiert gleich
nach dem Wechsel auch noch das
vorentscheidende 2:0 am Ende bejubeln
die Italiener ein klares 13:0
leichte Beine und Spaß hatte Benedikt
doll zum Auftakt des letzten
Biathlon-Weltcups dieses Winters in Oslo
der Lohn Rang 3 sein dritter Podestplatz
der Saison 41 Sekunden langsamer als der
erneut überragende Weltmeister Johannes
Böh aus Norwegen der damit alle sieben
Sprintwettbewerbe gewann ja eine
beeindruckende tolle Bilanz würde ich
sagen von leichten Beinen und Spaß
kommen wir jetzt zu ganz besonderen
Landschaftsaufnahmen veröffentlichtform
chinesischen Fernsehen ein Gebirgs See
im Nordwesten Chinas der spektakulär
blau erscheint weil sich mit dem
beginnenden Frühling die
Mineralzusammensetzung ändert ganz
andere Farben im Osten am Pazifik bunte
Priele geküsst von der untergehenden
Sonne aber wissen Sie was bei uns sind
auch tolle Farben unterwegs weil es wird
immer frühlingshafter Details dazu
gleich im Wetter mit Osten
um 21:45 Uhr empfehlen wir Ihnen das
heute journal mit Maria das longer unser
gesamtes 19 Uhr Team vor und hinter der
Kamera bedankt sich fürs zuschauen und
wünschen noch einen entspannten Abend
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter es wird mild in
Mitteleuropa und auch bei uns in
Deutschland 15 bis 20 Grad sind durchaus
drin und diese milde Luft kommt aus dem
Südwesten ja und hält sich am Wochenende
noch eine Weile bevor am Montag etwas
kühlere Luft sich durchsetzt aber das
nur vorübergehend in der Nacht gibt es
dann im Norden einige dichtere Wolken
mit Regen sonst klares meist auf nach
Südosten gibt's Nebel dort die einzige
Ecke wo es frostig wird mit werden bis
zu -3 Grad sonst häufig frostfrei ganz
im Westen am mildesten bei plus 7 Grad
ja und morgen dann ganz im Norden einige
Schauer sonst aber überwiegen trockenes
Wetter ganz im Süden Sonnenschein und
zum Nachmittag und abends von Südwesten
er etwas neuer Regen bei höchsten Werten
bis 12 Grad an der Ostsee häufig um die
15 Grad Marke im Südwesten 21 Grad die
nächsten Tage noch mit
20 Grad am Samstag mit Schauern und
Gewittern davon gibt's dann am Sonntag
noch mehr und Montag ein wenig kühler
bei 8 bis 16 Grad damit wünsche ich
Ihnen einen schönen Abend